after the defeat
just now it would be better to win
him from
so we always played with f4
his wife prix
attacks but none he
continued really funny actually it
all fits together now what he did was nothing at all
so
well  yes, and i can
still capture and now white somehow has
an isolated pawn position
with the strange move f4, as if he were
claiming two hours, everything would be
fine, but of course that looks funny,
how is the best way to play here now
over 56 maybe
fighting the field
yes ok he makes it easy of course
now we no longer have isolated
pawns
and now it's just the four
or not the 4
yes yes just before that he had about
the same rating and played a really
decent game and here
is it better to get something funny out of
here
jumper or
no means jumper away or that
tends to be more and more dangerous b  stranded game
like luca 7
so now we have a passed
pawn because that's how ag 4 runs
then he just has
to exchange
the queen here or after that the design is simply
means yes too